au gouvernement la parole est à monsieur
arnaud robinet pour le groupe l'est
républicain
ma question s'adresse à la ministre de
la santé
la lenteur des procédures législatives
et des affaires parlementaires au moins
un mérite celui de montrer aux français
l'ampleur de l'impasse de votre
politique ça tapas commence avec un
grand ti icom improvisation tout d'abord
sur le principe même de ce texte
annoncée en 2012 ce projet de loi
n'arrive qu'en seconde moitié du
quinquennat et ses principales mesures
comme le tiers payant généralisé sont si
mal préparés que leur application a
renvoyé à après 2017
eacom indifférence à l'égard des
terroirs à l'égard des femmes et des
hommes qui ont fait progresser leur
appellation qui font le rayonnement
international de la france et qu'ils
n'ont pas être traités comme les
empoisonneurs de notre jeunesse et je
salue le vote de la commission des
affaires sociales il comme idéologie
avec cette méfiance à l'égard de
l'industrie de santé qui subissent le
yoyo des taxes et des règles en tout
genre i comme idéologie encore avec
cette obsession d'opposer le public au
privé avec des règles différentes
appliquer des praticiens qui font le
même métier soigner les français madame
la ministre
les français ont le droit de choisir
leur médecin et leur chirurgien en toute
confiance il comme à tolérance comme
l'intolérance au dialogue que vous
développez face aux professionnels de
santé et qui sont obligés de multiplier
les journées de grève
comme ce vendredi pour obtenir une autre
réponse que votre condescendance
technocratique
eacom incapacité enfin devant les vrais
enjeux de la santé au quotidien votre
projet de loi ne dit rien sur la
rémunération des médecins et rien non
plus sur les restes à charge qui font
qu'aujourd'hui des millions de français
renoncent aux soins dentaires et
optiques
enfin i comme icare comme icare que vous
imitez depuis 2012 ycare s'est brûlé les
ailes en voulant trop s'approcher du
soleil et comme lui à trop vouloir
s'approcher d'un modèle étatiste vous
allez détruire notre système de santé
oui madame la ministre votre projet de
loi ni gravement à la santé
alors changez le pendant qu'il est
encore temps
merci monsieur robinet la parole est à
madame la secrétaire d'état chargée de
la famille de l'enfance et des personnes
âgées et de l'autonomie monsieur le
président monsieur le député arnaud
robinet mesdames et messieurs les
députés je souhaite d'abord excusé
l'absence de marisol touraine retenus à
cet instant dans l'autre assemblée et
vous dire que monsieur robinet je
pourrais peut-être continuer ico mim
modestie de votre question ico y comme
influences verbal
i comme monsieur de robinets pourquoi
tant de mots droite en deux mots cette
question avec cette loi
nous misons sur la prévention avec
étiquetage nutritionnel simplifiée nous
luttons contre l'attrait du tabac en
particulier chez les jeunes avec le
paquet neutre
nous combattons l'alcoolisation
excessive qui fait également tant de mal
à la jeunesse et nous créons le médecin
traitant pour les enfants avec ses toits
nous permettons à notre système de santé
de se moderniser en se réorganisant
autour de la coordination de soins de
proximité et du médecin traitant
nous créons un numéro de garde pour
trouver un professionnel de santé près
de chez soi à toute heure avec ses toits
nous permettons enfin le franchissement
d'une nouvelle étape de la démocratie
sanitaire
l'ouverture des données santé nous
créons l'action de groupe en santé pour
permettre aux patients aux malades de
portée devant les tribunaux leur action
c'est toi santé la loi qui est attendu
par l'ensemble des preuves et des
patients sédunois juste c'est une loi
qui est c'est une loi qui va venir
parachever l'oeuvre que nous conduisons
depuis 2012 réaffirmé leur attachement à
la production collective assurer la
sécurité sociale assainir les comptes de
l'assurance maladie sans ne jamais ni
déremboursés ni altéré l'accès au soin
voire même comme nous le faisons en
améliorant l'accès aux soins
merci malin ministre la parole est à mme
e